oh hello you've interrupted me in my
easy chair as always I'm Peter Rubin
senior editor at wired and this week we
are going to talk about one of my most
anticipated comic book launches of the
year we are going to talk about perhaps
the best way for you to destroy your
workday productivity for the foreseeable
future but first we're going to talk
about Total Recall why are we going to
talk about Total Recall you ask I do not
want to see a new Total Recall I enjoyed
the original total Rico very much I once
thought like you I once said i enjoyed
Arnold Schwarzenegger in this role I do
not want to see Colin Farrell playing
Quaid I do not want to see len wiseman
directing i said i enjoyed paul
verhoeven version very much however the
more footage I've seen from this movie
the more I've become convinced that they
are actually doing this the right way
when Wiseman is set up some really
imaginative imaginative sorry big word
can't be helped imaginative looking
action sequences he's filming it in a
kind of pretty cool style great stunt
work by colin farrell kate beckinsale
and Jessica Biel among others and what I
like the most is there are numerous
homages to the original total recall
that Paul Verhoeven made but he kind of
steps one way or the other at the last
minute kind of subverts those things so
there are a lot of sly nods to the
original without borrowing wholesale
from them which I enjoy it very much
that being said Total Recall I will be
in line this friday and i hope to see
you there but let's talk about video
games with our men on the scene
okay so sometimes I talk about video
games which is kind of unfair because I
tend to forget that not everybody has a
video game machine a magic box that lets
them do this but if you're watching this
you do have a computer and you are
online because you're watching this so
let me tell you about an incredible game
that is actually now available to play
in your browser and that game is
spelunky it has been around for a couple
of years as a windows game but last
month it was brought to xbox live as an
xbox live arcade release it was enhanced
in and beefed up and came out and people
went absolutely nuts over it it is an
8-bit platformer with a serious serious
difficulty curve if you die the game is
over none of this continued none of
those three lives none of this put in
the konami code and get 99 guys play
contra with it is serious tough
platforming and now someone has ported
dare accuse great game over to a browser
version so they're still ironing out
some kinks and the sound isn't in yet I
imagine it will be very soon but it went
online earlier this week and now you can
play it we're going to put the link on
the screen right now so go to this link
and play spelunky and because you die
and the game is over you will play again
and then you will play again and then
again and perhaps again and as you get
better and better you will get more and
more frustrated when you die so you will
keep playing and keep playing and keep
playing and eventually you will be fired
and I apologize for that back to you
okay I thank you for that I'm sure my
boss thanks you as well let's talk about
comic books let's talk about one of my
favorite comic book teams coming back
together and that is writer Matt
Fraction who was one of my absolute
favorite writers working in comics today
an illustrator David aha they worked
together on the immortal iron fist a few
years ago and they are back working with
Marvel on a superhero who well is really
a superhero Hawkeye I never liked the
guy that much in the Avengers he's kind
of the guy without a superpower he he
has a good aim great for him I never
really cared that has changed because in
their hands they have created this
character or recreated this character
that that really draws you in now the
first issue of Hawkeye kind of deals
with clint barton he lives in brooklyn
he's got kind of a close to home thing
an issue to take care of so this is not
really an Avengers focused issue what it
does is it really gives you a sense of
who Clint Barton is he knows he doesn't
have any superpowers it makes them act a
certain kind of way feel a certain kind
of way but it gives you some really good
insight into the guys psyche and it
takes place in August in Brooklyn which
if you have never lived there I spent a
very long time living there it is one of
the most miserable situations you can be
in it is muggy it is hot everyone's just
mad all the time especially in bed-stuy
which is where Clint Barton lives so
fantastic atmospheric artwork by David
AHA and and great writing as always from
matt fraction some people think he can
go a little over the top with some of
the embellishments i really like the
stuff i find it incredibly naturalistic
and enjoyable and the cadences are great
so hawkeye number one out this week no
brainer for me and I anticipate this is
going to go in some great directions so
that is it for the monitor we will be
back next week until then you can email
us at the monitor at wired.com for
suggestions questions criticisms law
dacians if you want to send me a garland
of roses I may wear it in circling my
brow next week I doubt you will do that
but just in case I wanted to leave it
open but until then until we are back
with more pop culture fantastic
inspirational catchphrase here
you